وقد طلب بندوبه وفلسطين لدى الامم المتحده
رياض منصور مجلس الامن باستخدام نفوذه
لانهاء الاحتلال والاعتراف بدوله فلسطين
قبل فوات الاوان وقال خلال جلسه ان لمجلس
الامن الاسرائيل تنتهك القانون الدولي
وتتمتع مع ذلك بالافلاتي من العقاب
ون القانون الدوليه بالافلاه من العقاب
ويتحمل العقاب الجماعيه من لديه الحق في
الحمايه اسرائيل تعتبروا ان العالم لا
يستطيع محاسبتها على افعلها غير القانونيه
ومع ذلك فانها تسمح لنفسها بمعاقبتنا على
اللجوء الى اليات مشروعات متعدده الاطراف
اخر مثال على ذلك هو قرار اسرائيل ترضع
عقوبات على الشعب الفلسطيني والمجتمع
المدني والقياده اعرب اكثر من 100 بلد عن
رفضهم لذلك ودعوني تراجع عن هذه التدابير
العقابيه